[Music]
I'm very curious what was your reaction
to reading the script for the first time
that had three really complicated and
textured female characters in it let me
do my part two then one of the things I
think that Marvel does so brilliantly is
that each of their films pushes the
comic book movie genre forward in a new
way can you sort of talk about that
aspect of Black Widow well I think in a
way my answer just then did in that
there are not one not two but three
three three female parts is David Harbor
as well yes I think he's unlike I I
can't think of another Marvel story
whether three three lead females can you
I cannot yeah like this yes it makes it
pretty unusual and feisty and also very
vulnerable last thing can you what can
you see he's actually about your
character what can I tell you she's
called milena
she's been cycled through the read
through the Red Room Black Widow program
five times so she's a pretty highly
skilled spy and assassin she's deeply
involved in some scientific research
that's all I can say I thank you so much
I cannot wait to see it thank you